[Música]
que lindo né gente deu risada chorou
teve raiva a falou coisas é
impressionante
a única coisa que não pode ter a única
coisa que não dá né
acho que tudo tudo tudo menos
indiferença 6 lindos netão aqui vieram
aqui porque não são indiferentes quem
está assistindo não está indiferente na
indiferença pessoas
a indiferença a aaa perspectivas
expectativas visões demandas né
é triste você ver a indiferença o que
ela produz né
eu quero refletir um pouco claro sempre
com esse tema que eu gosto tanto 41 anos
trabalhando com essas questões 21
ambiente empresarial mas 40 anos 41
lidando com as questões compartilhar um
pouco com vocês um aspecto dessa
conversa sobre diversidade e inclusão
que é como a gente transforma
características nossas em motivos pra
privilégios
pra mim é as autuações de coisas e aí
como a gente transforma também essas
características em motivo para a
violência sem motivo para desigualdades
desvantagens enfim a gente transforma
característica sem motivo para
privilégios e aqui a gente falou muito
né eu como homem branco tem que colocar
isso não fui eu que criei essa expressão
mas um jornalista branco como eu dizendo
eu tenho que saber que é como se eu
tivesse com a cor da minha pele com a
komeco meu jeito como se fosse um
passaporte onde eu posso entrar nos
lugares até o fim
onde eu passo até por uma blitz em levar
200 tiros né
onde eu
tenho que ter essa noção né de que
privilégio é exatamente você se
beneficiar da desigualdade dos outros né
então isso é um privilégio não é a gente
trabalhar e todo mundo trabalho a não é
dizer sim eu lutei tanto tal é você tem
uma característica que te dá esse
passaporte essas situações pra gente
pensar pra gente pensar né
nós homens somos 90% dos cargos de
liderança cargos executivos nas empresas
87 para ser mais justo 87% 87% e ainda
tem gente que a ouvir essas conversas
todas que a gente trouxe aqui com
histórias de vida com visões com
expressões ainda acho que nossa agora
tudo pra eles fala puxa 90% pegando a
questão racial só 5,7 por cento de
negros em cargos executivos vão pegar o
cargo executivo como lugar onde algumas
pessoas querem e podem e deveriam poder
chegar lá né 5,7 quando você pega
mulheres negras em cargos executivos eu
não falei mas nas 500 maiores empresas
falei 500 novas empresas mais chiques as
mais poderosas mulheres negras em cargos
executivos 0,4 por cento
então escutar todas as histórias que a
gente escuta essa afirmação negra essa
necessidade da gente ser tão branco
quanto negro nessas nesses espaços
nessas coisas todas vejam como a gente
está longe
a gente cria problemas a cria
dificuldades transforma característica
sem motivo para a violência só problemas
e isso traz problemas das pessoas e traz
problemas para nós mesmos né
ah eu gosto de citar o meu meu meu caso
aí no meio dessas questões todas com
cordas muitas características mas se a
gente tem problema com características
não vai dar uma coisa boa né
eu vou usar o termo técnico aqui né
marcadores e identitários
um dos termos para dizer esse conjunto
de características que nós temos
e aí durante o dia a gente viu né acho
que duas mensagens que eu gosto também
de reforçar que uma levando sua bandeira
levando sua mão fale diga porque senão
vão passar por cima de você
se não vão ignorar você no meio do
caminho senão na hora da gente planejar
o mundo vai esquecer de alguns de nós ea
ideia como foi dito aqui não deixe
ninguém para trás
essa idéia como humanidade eu acho que é
razoável é possível
a outra idéia é complementar à essa não
nega é assim por outro lado não deixe
que ninguém te reduza a um dos teus
marcadores e identitários que ninguém te
reduz a uma das suas características
nem você mesmo se reduzir nós somos isso
aquele muito mais não foi o de júnior
falou isso várias pessoas trouxeram essa
imagem não suma com as minhas
características por outro lado não me
reduza a uma delas eu tenho várias
características
eu não sou sua mulher eu não sou só isso
não sou só aquilo isso não quer dizer
que você não perceber como na sociedade
brasileira na minha opinião e de tantos
outros mas é compartilhando com vocês
minha visão essa visão da diversidade
humana não quer dizer que a gente não
tenha que ter os temas principais na
minha história pra minha visão de mundo
por aquilo que o estudo pra mim a
questão racial
qualquer questão que você cruzar com a a
ser mulher ser uma pessoa lgbt e ser uma
pessoa com deficiência qualquer coisa
que você cruza com a questão racial
você tem aí um problemão isso mostra que
para a nossa sociedade brasileira
a gente vai ter sempre que está lidando
com essa questão a prender um jeito de
viver juntos na humanidade enfrentar
aquilo que está aí
aaaah colocado por baixo de um tapete
eternamente como foi dito invisibilidade
histórias não ditos né
nas muitas características aí isso não é
falta minha tap que pobre não tem foto
de infância
não é duro achar então achei lá no no no
no nosso site na nas fotos né
mas eu fui para a escola nos anos 60
chegou lá a professora no primeiro dia
de aula tudo contente né assustado mas
contente vendo os amiguinhos a
professora descobre que eu sou canhoto e
eu contei outro dia essa história de dar
um efeito bom pra lembrar nem parece uma
coisa banal ser canhoto mas é assim a
banalidade é da violência contra nossas
características também a professora
descobriu que era canhoto falou nossa
isso é indecente me botou na frente da
sala é indecente imoral
isso aqui não pode é errado tal eu ela
nem sabia que eu era gay
se ela soubesse ela tinha dito coisas
sabe deus o que minha mãe resolveu isso
né
mas é um exemplo para dizer sem puxa a a
às vezes as pessoas dizem coisas
horrorosas da gente a gente pode
acreditar no caso durou pouco porque a
minha mãe de novo resolveu isso né
ela foi lá de um esculacho o professor
desde menino sei o que ele quer
eu gostei da ideia mas às vezes idéias
tortas podem morar na cabeça da gente
por muito tempo a gente viu aqui também
algumas pessoas falando isso como é que
a gente se reinventa se desintoxica sei
lá todas as expressões que a gente possa
usar para pensar nessas idéias erradas
né
como é que a ideia de bom e ruim certo e
errado normal anormal bonito reio
confiável seguro interessante enfim como
é que isso foi morar na tua cabeça é uma
das reflexões que pensar nessa
transformação de características em
motivo para privilégios ou para
violências a faz a gente pensar e calma
não é para jogar tudo fora então é mesmo
ensinar o que é bonito é isso fez aquilo
não quero mais nada não a ideia é só
saiba a origem de onde veio tem coisa
que nem vai conseguir descobrir mas
assim se a propiedade disso esse é o tal
do viés inconsciente ou dos preconceitos
estereótipos
base em estereótipos e as práticas de
discriminação se a propina aquilo ali eu
tenho como critério de novo
compartilhando com vocês eu tenho como
critério pensar aquilo me ajuda na minha
relação comigo mesmo esse conceito de
certo e errado bom bonito ou seja lá o
que fosse os valores às questões essas
visões de mundo elas me ajudam na minha
relação comigo mesmo e com as pessoas e
para as pessoas viverem juntas e melhor
em paz
é um critério é uma forma de você jogar
algumas coisas fora sou revelou se
reinventar ou se desintoxicar ou achar
aí todos os remédios que a gente possa
assinar é para fazer a ponte com a maria
vitória linda maravilhosa né
que história bonita de alguém tão jovem
eu talvez não tem idade pra ver tudo o
que ela pode fazer onde ela pode chegar
né mas é fantástico é óbvio que ela vai
chegar em algum lugar bacana
se a gente pegar essas questões e pensar
sobre ela sobre como foram morar dentro
da gente é uma coisa sobre transformar
característica sem motivo para
desigualdades para violências para
desvantagens para vulnerabilidades para
tudo isso e para você essa educação para
indiferença também fiquei muito pensando
sobre isso né eu fui lá na minha origem
descobrir assim puxa eu fui educado acho
que vocês também mas o melhor dizendo
não sei vocês mas pensei nisso eu fui
educado para não reparar em nada para
não prestar atenção em nada nas coisas
então eu gosto de comprar também a
história da dd na casa da mãe dadá na
casa da amiga da minha mãe tinha lá um
pingüim na geladeira na minha casa não
tinha um pingüim na geladeira quando
chegou nessa uma geladeira melhor mais
nova inclusive foi um auê numa festa o
rei do pinguim me chamou atenção pra mim
era novo era inusitado era algo fora do
comum eu botei o dedinho lá para dizer
olha um pinguim
o que é aquilo em cima da geladeira
aquela coisa toda tal minha mãe muito
elegante e muito educada uma pessoa
muito correta e 1
na minha mão aquela mãe que me salvou lá
do outro por outro lado ela deu ela deu
um tapa na minha mão e disse a frase que
é o marco dessa nossa educação não
repare não repare respeitar e não
reparar e não olhar não comentar
ela deu um tapa na minha curiosidade na
minha criatividade ela me deu um tapa
imagine um pequeno cientista porque é
isso que nós somos como estamos chegando
no planeta não é pessoa linhas
pequenininhas criancinhas olhando para o
mundo nós somos pequenos cientistas
curiosos contudo ela podia ter dito
repare mesmo olhe tudo né tudo é novo
pra você mas vejo que você vai fazer com
que você tá botando de reparo
o que você vai se humilhar em relação ao
pingüim na geladeira do vizinho ou você
vai dizer que aquilo é brega ridículo
não só quer fazer julgamentos de
imediato saber lidar com as
características
uma das coisas é certa não suba com isso
dando um exemplo bacana a tem a ver com
a nossa colega que nem eu vivi uma
situação numa fábrica gosta de contar
isso mas foram muitas situações com uma
pessoa que não tinha braços e ela
trabalhando numa empresa o gestor vai me
dizer eu gosto de cumprimentar todo
mundo e com aquela pessoa que não tinha
braços no caso não tinha braços nem mãos
é diferente nos vemos uma situação
parecida e ela ele gestor dizendo eu não
sei o que fazer
aí eu dei um tapa no bumbum dela da
minha funcionária outro dia como uma
forma de cumprimentá lá né
pegou mal na empresa foi um horror tão
também a moça dizer pois é faz seis
meses que estou convivendo com esse
gestor se gostou nela está a faz seis
gestor ele não sabe como falar comigo é
um dos efeitos de você não reparar de
você não sabe lidar com as
características de você ter essa
educação de achar que a gente não deve
olhar reparar conversar dialogar sobre
as nossas características vez que em
nenhum momento eu estou tentando evitar
é a palavra diferença
o que há são características a gente
transforma diferente em relação a quem
né
aqui nessa relação não somos seres
incolores inodoros insípidos imóveis em
forma sem vida né
a nós temos que lidar com a construção
da igualdade como foi dito aqui a
construção da equidade né mais do que a
igualdade tem que considerar as
características das pessoas para que o
planejamento do nosso mundo não deixe
ninguém atrás
não deixe ninguém de lado não deixe
ninguém do lado de fora né
outra experiência que eu tive para
terminar uma empresa a pessoa um grupo
de funcionários dizendo olha precisamos
tratar todo mundo igual
e aí uma funcionária levantou falou eu
quero uma sala de amamentação eu voltei
da licença-maternidade agora meu peito
está cheio quero dá leite para o meu
bebê
esse negócio de tratar tudo igual mas eu
tenho uma questão quantas mulheres estão
aqui era um grupo de homens quanto as
mulheres estão aqui que voltaram da
licença que estão com o peito cheio que
gostaria de levar o leite para o seu
bebê para casa sabe onde eu tiro leite
no banheiro da empresa o lugar mais sujo
que tem sabe qual foi a proposta vai
propor um ambulatório outro lugar cheio
de gente gripada doente não dá certo
foi bacana colocar ali essa questão pra
ver não trata igual né
considere as questões por que não uma
sala de amamentação bonitinho uma
geladeirinha uma cadeira há algo assim
construir o mundo com base no homem
vitruviano construir o mundo com base em
padrões dominantes é fácil a cadeira que
está sentado tudo aqui à nossa volta
gente tem que considerar todos nós se
tem aqui todo mundo me escutando tal
isso tem um colega surdo
como é que nós vamos investir né pra que
tenha libras para que tenha a
transmissão de a a áudio-descrição
porque nessa questão da democracia é
importante que não fazem tudo não estava
escutando aqui todo mundo a maioria tá
só tem um que nós
tá e aí a gente joga essa pessoa fora né
a ideia é uma pessoa importa cada um de
nós é o único especial cada um de nós é
uma das soluções que a vida encontrou
dentro das muitas e muitas composições
possíveis
o importa 1 importa
ficamos com essa idéia fiquemos com os
muitos convites que foram dados aqui
ficamos com a ideia como dispor valeri
que o que há de mais profundo em nós é a
pele né por falar de flor de pele
flo à flor da pele quantos convites
foram feitos
pense nisso um importa cada um de nós a
importa muito obrigado
[Aplausos]